From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And let's head back in time-- back to when being on TV meant you sort of half-shouted every single thing you said.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。让我们回到过去——回到那个电视节目里每一句话都要半喊半叫才能说出来的年代。
This is the primate laboratory at the University of Wisconsin in Madison.
这是威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校的灵长类动物实验室。
The year is 1960.
时间是1960年。
In this laboratory, there are approximately 120 rhesus monkeys-- the subject of a study that wants to know the answer to the question, what is an infant's love for its mother?
在这个实验室里，大约有120只恒河猴——它们是一项研究的对象，这项研究旨在探寻一个问题的答案：婴儿对母亲的爱究竟是什么？
Now, the reason there even was a study asking this very basic question, back when CBS Television took a camera crew to Wisconsin-- well, that is actually the kind of thing that most of us today would find sort of surprising. You see, the researcher that they're filming-- a guy named Harry Harlow, was trying to prove-- I know this is going to sound crazy-- he was trying to prove that love is an important thing that happens between parents and children.
事实上，在哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）的摄制组前往威斯康星州拍摄时，竟然会有这样一项研究来探究如此基本的问题，这在今天的大多数人看来其实有点令人惊讶。你们看，他们拍摄的那位研究员——一个叫哈里·哈洛的人，试图证明——我知道这听起来很疯狂——他试图证明爱是父母与子女之间发生的一种重要事物。
And the reason why he felt the need to prove this point was, at the time-- and, again, I know this is going to sound kind of out there-- the psychological establishment, pediatricians, even the federal government were all saying exactly the opposite of that to parents.
他之所以觉得有必要证明这一点，是因为在当时——再说一遍，我知道这听起来有些不可思议——心理学界、儿科医生，甚至是联邦政府，都在对家长们说着完全相反的观点。
It's actually one of those things that you say, how could they have thought that? But psychology just didn't believe in love. And if you go back and you pull any of the psychology textbooks, really almost pre-1950, you don't even find it in the index because it was not a word that was used.
这真是那种会让你感叹“他们怎么会那样想”的事情之一。但当时的心理学界就是不相信爱。如果你去翻阅1950年以前的任何心理学教科书，你甚至在索引里都找不到这个词，因为它根本就不是一个会被使用的词。
This is Deborah Blum, the biographer of this renegade researcher, Harry Harlow. She writes about how psychologists at the time actually saw loving behavior towards children as a problem, a menace. At one point, the head of the American Psychological Association declared, "When you're tempted to pet your child, remember that mother love is a dangerous instrument."
这位研究员哈里·哈洛的传记作者黛博拉·布鲁姆向我们介绍了这一情况。她在书中写道，当时的心理学家实际上将对孩子表现出爱意视为一个问题，一种威胁。曾有一位美国心理学会主席宣称：“当你想要亲昵你的孩子时，请记住，母爱是一种危险的工具。”
Yeah, that was John Watson. And he actually said there are serious rocks ahead for the over-kissed child, and then defined over-kissing as kissing your child more than once a year.
没错，那是约翰·沃森。他甚至说“过度亲昵的孩子前方有严重的险阻”，并把“过度亲昵”定义为一年亲吻孩子超过一次。
Wow.
哇。
I mean, that was the message of almost everything.
我的意思是，当时几乎所有的信息都在传递这个观点。
Yeah. At some point, there are government pamphlets, you write, that are warning parents not to touch their children, and you quote some. One says, "Never kiss a baby, especially on the mouth. Don't rock or play with children."
是的。你曾写道，当时甚至还有政府小册子警告父母不要碰自己的孩子，你还引用了一些。其中一本写着：“永远不要亲吻婴儿，尤其不要亲吻嘴部。不要摇晃或与孩子玩耍。”
Yeah. Not to say that everyone follows what so-called experts do, right? But, certainly, you had an enormous effect of this affection is wrong, love isn't real-- trust us, we're scientists-- that greatly shaped those kind of perceptions.
是的。并不是说每个人都会遵循那些所谓的专家的意见，对吧？但毫无疑问，这种“情感是错误的，爱不是真实的——相信我们，我们是科学家”的观念产生了巨大的影响，极大地塑造了当时人们的看法。
How is this possible? Well, first of all, psychology was still pretty young, and psychologists hadn't figured out how to measure love, how to quantify it, talk about it in a scientific way. So the thinking about love's role was incredibly crude.
这怎么可能呢？首先，当时的心理学还很年轻，心理学家们还没弄明白如何衡量爱、如何量化爱，以及如何以科学的方式谈论它。所以，关于爱之作用的思考在当时极其粗糙。
And at the same time-- this is all at the beginning of the early 20th century-- medicine was still figuring out how bacteria spread infections. And pediatricians had noticed that, in hospitals, the kids who were picked up a lot by nurses seemed to get more infections.
与此同时——这都是20世纪初的事——医学界还在研究细菌是如何传播感染的。儿科医生们注意到，在医院里，那些常被护士抱起来的孩子似乎更容易感染。
So doctors were saying, don't pick up your child, don't pick up your child, don't pick up your child. So you had a kind of confluence going there. You had pediatricians saying, we're telling you for health reasons that you should never cuddle your child or indulge them. And guess what? Psychology says if you follow those rules, if you show your child no affection, you will make them a better human being. So back off.
所以医生们就说，不要抱你的孩子，不要抱你的孩子，不要抱你的孩子。于是，多种因素在这里交汇了。一方面是儿科医生说，我们出于健康理由告诫你们永远不要拥抱或溺爱孩子。而且你猜怎么着？心理学说，如果你遵守这些规则，如果你对孩子表现出冷漠，你反而会把他们培养成更好的人。所以，离孩子远点吧。
And this is the way it was for decades, until about the 1940s. Health care workers started to notice that some children in hospitals, in orphanages, who were treated this way never picked up, never loved, would wither and die-- literally die. But even this did not change the opinion of the psychological establishment.
这种情况持续了几十年，直到20世纪40年代左右。医护人员开始注意到，在医院和孤儿院里，那些被这样对待——从不被抱起、从不被爱——的孩子会枯萎并死去——字面意义上的死亡。但即使是这样，也没有改变心理学界的观点。
So enter Harry Harlow. He sets out to prove that love is important-- in fact, love is a key to normal development in children-- and that what bonds babies and mothers is more than just the baby's need for food.
于是哈里·哈洛登场了。他着手证明爱是重要的——事实上，爱是儿童正常发育的关键——并且婴儿与母亲之间的纽带不仅仅源于婴儿对食物的需求。
Now this is what we tried. The responses of the baby monkey are very similar to those of the human babies.
现在，这就是我们的实验尝试。小猴子的反应与人类婴儿非常相似。
This is Harry Harlow on CBS in 1960. In the cage with the baby monkey are two dolls.
这是1960年哈里·哈洛在CBS节目中的镜头。在装有小猴子的笼子里有两个玩偶。
We constructed two substitute mothers. They have absolute patience. They are available 24 hours a day. The mother hits the baby with love.
我们制造了两个替代母猴。它们有绝对的耐心。它们一天24小时都在那里。母猴用爱包裹着宝宝。
What he did is he gave them two alternative dummy mothers. One was a wire mother with an ugly face, and one was a cloth mother. She had sort of a fluffy terry cloth body.
他所做的是给它们提供了两个替代的假母亲。一个是长着丑陋面孔的铁丝母猴，另一个是布料母猴。她有着毛茸茸的毛巾布身体。
These are the only mothers these babies ever had.
这是这些宝宝拥有的仅有的母亲。
And in the simplest experiment, baby monkey would be put in a cage with both mothers, but wire mother had the milk. So by all the theories, the baby should bond to wire mother, because she's feeding him.
在最简单的实验中，小猴子会被放进一个同时有这两个母亲的笼子里，但铁丝母猴身上有奶水。所以按照所有的理论，宝宝应该依附于铁丝母猴，因为它在喂它。
Here's Baby 106. Watch.
看看106号宝宝。看着。
The little baby monkey-- which, by the way, is the most insanely cute thing you have ever seen-- scampers under the wire mother, which is like a wire, mesh cylinder with a boxy head and eyes, apparently made from a billiard ball. The monkey sucks from a bottle that comes out of its chest, and then it runs to cuddle with the other mother.
这只小猴子——顺便说一句，它是我见过最可爱的小东西——跑到了铁丝母猴身下，那铁丝母猴看起来就像一个铁丝网圆筒，顶着一个方方正正的头和眼睛，眼睛显然是用台球做的。猴子从它胸部伸出的奶瓶吸奶，然后它跑去拥抱另一个母亲。
Oh, he's going back. He's back on the cloth mother, and he'll stay on the cloth mother. Actually, this baby spends 17 to 18 hours a day on the cloth mother, and less than one hour a day on the wire mother.
噢，它回去了。它又回到了布料母猴身上，它会待在布料母猴那里。事实上，这只宝宝每天在布料母猴身上待17到18个小时，而在铁丝母猴身上不到一小时。
The monkey rubs itself against the cloth doll until it seems to get some solace from it, and then it relaxes. In other experiments, it comes back to the cloth doll for reassurance when it's put into scary situations. When the cloth mom is nearby, the baby is curious. It walks around and explores. It's confident.
这只猴子在布绒玩偶身上蹭来蹭去，直到它似乎从中获得了安慰，然后放松下来。在其他实验中，当它被置于可怕的环境中时，它会回到布绒玩偶身边寻求慰藉。当布料妈妈在附近时，宝宝会感到好奇。它会四处走动探索。它很自信。
And this is how Harlow proved that the relationship between mother and child is more than just about getting food. The baby monkeys needed something else, something that had to do with being cuddled and touched and reassured.
这就是哈洛证明母亲与孩子之间的关系不仅仅是为了获取食物的方法。小猴子需要别的东西，一些与被拥抱、被触摸和被安抚有关的东西。
It was clear that in this sort of cuddly feeling of affection came all kinds of really important developmental responses. You know, security, curiosity is essential or more essential than being fed.
很显然，这种被拥抱的温情感受带来了一系列非常重要的发育反应。你知道，安全感、好奇心比被喂饱更重要，甚至是最重要的。
One of the other Harlow experiments was one in which they took nice, cuddly, ever welcoming cloth mother, and they made her into an abusive mother or a rejecting mother. Harlow called these evil mothers. One of the cloth moms had brass spikes embedded that would shoot out when the baby monkey held on. I mean, they were blunt tipped. It didn't cut them to shreds but they hurt. And one was like a shaking mom.
哈洛的另一个实验是，他们把那个温柔、总是欢迎它们的布料妈妈变成了一个虐待型或排斥型的母亲。哈洛称这些为“邪恶母亲”。其中一个布料妈妈装有黄铜尖刺，当小猴子抱住它时，尖刺就会弹出来。我的意思是，它们是钝头的。它不会把它们切成碎片，但会很痛。还有一个是像会摇晃的妈妈。
Harlow wrote very graphically. He said the babies would be shaken till their teeth and bones rattled in unison. And one would just hurl the baby away. It was spring loaded.
哈洛的描述非常生动。他说宝宝们会被摇晃到它们的牙齿和骨头一起咔哒作响。还有一种会直接把宝宝弹开。它是弹簧驱动的。
But what they found was that when the mom quit-- spikes retracted or shaking stopped-- the babies came back and they did everything they could to make those mothers love them again. And then they cooed and they stroked and they'd groom and they'd flirt, and exactly what human babies do with their moms.
但他们发现，当妈妈停止动作——尖刺收回或停止摇晃时——宝宝们又会回来，它们会尽其所能让那些母亲再次爱它们。它们会咕咕叫、抚摸、梳理毛发，还会撒娇，这正是人类婴儿对待母亲的方式。
And they would abandon their friends. They had to fix this relationship. It was so important to them.
它们甚至会抛弃同伴。它们必须修复这段关系。这对比它们来说太重要了。
Harlow spent years as an outcast, fighting for his ideas, before things finally changed. Though Harlow, he did so much to convince people that a parent's love for a child is one of the most important things that anyone could ever get or need, he did not have so much success with the love in his own life. He was notoriously cold.
哈洛作为一名被排斥者奋斗多年，为自己的理念而战，直到情况最终改变。虽然哈洛为让人们相信父母对孩子的爱是每个人最重要、最需要的财富做出了巨大贡献，但他在自己的生活中并没有那么成功地收获爱。他出了名的冷漠。
He had a wicked tongue and everyone lived a little bit in fear of it. He was not at all a warm and fuzzy person, and he certainly wasn't a warm and fuzzy father. He had four children by two different marriages. Almost all of them, his children-- the ones I talked to-- remember him as being gone.
他言辞刻薄，每个人都有点怕他。他根本不是一个热情亲切的人，当然也不是一个热情亲切的父亲。他通过两段婚姻有了四个孩子。几乎所有孩子——那些我采访过的——都记得他是个“缺席者”。
Was he self aware enough to actually understand how publicly he loved the idea of love, but in his private life he wasn't carrying it out?
他是否有足够的自我意识去理解，他在公开场合如此推崇“爱”的理念，而在私生活中却并未践行呢？
I don't think he was maybe until the end of his life. And he had difficulty in a lot of relationships.
我不认为他理解，也许直到生命尽头才有所觉悟。他在许多人际关系中都存在困难。
In a way, of course, who else would be so interested in how does love work, except for somebody who really needs to figure it out? Well, today on our program, stories of unconditional love. If you can get a monkey to love a terry cloth towel with a cue ball on its head, it doesn't seem like it should be so hard with your own kids, right?
从某种程度上讲，当然了，除了那些真正需要弄明白爱的人，还有谁会对爱是如何运作的如此感兴趣呢？好吧，今天我们的节目主题是：无条件的爱的故事。如果你能让一只猴子去爱一条套着台球头的毛巾，那对自己的孩子做到这一点应该没那么难吧，对吧？
We have two stories today of parents and children, and exactly what unconditional love gets you. We first ran today's show all the way back in 2006. Act One of our show, Love is a Battlefield. Act Two, Hit Me With Your Best Shot. Stay with us.
今天我们有两个关于父母与子女的故事，以及无条件的爱究竟能带来什么。我们第一次播出今天的节目是在2006年。第一幕：爱是战场。第二幕：尽情打击我吧。敬请关注。
Act One-- Love is a Battlefield. In this act, a family faces a kind of profound question. Can you teach love, even to a child who has all sorts of reasons not to learn love? Alix Spiegel has this story.
第一幕——爱是战场。在这一幕中，一个家庭面临着一个深刻的问题。你能教会爱吗？即使是对一个有各种理由不去学习爱的孩子？阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）带来了这个故事。
Until he was seven years old, Daniel Solomon slept sitting up. This wasn't because upright was a particularly comfortable position or because some exotic medical condition prevented him from straightening at the waist. It was just because Daniel didn't have another option. For the first seven years of his life, he lived in a crib in an orphanage in Romania with another child his age.
在七岁之前，丹尼尔·所罗门（Daniel Solomon）睡觉时总是坐着。这并不是因为坐着睡觉特别舒服，或者是因为某种奇怪的疾病让他无法躺平。只是因为丹尼尔别无选择。在他生命的前七年里，他一直住在罗马尼亚一家孤儿院的婴儿床里，和一个与他同龄的孩子住在一起。
His name was Niku, and he was more a shy kid. He didn't really talk much. And, I mean, it was kind of weird but it was fun to have him in there. It was-- I don't know what we even did, but we were there for seven and a half years and we got along, I guess.
他的名字叫尼库（Niku），他是个比较害羞的孩子。他其实话不多，而且，我的意思是，那时候很奇怪但也有点趣。我们在一起——我不知道我们具体做了什么，但我们在那里待了七年半，我想我们相处得还不错。
During the day, one set of adults would feed and clean Daniel, Niku, and the other 100 or so orphans who lived in the same room. During the night, there was a graveyard crew. But even though Daniel was there for seven and a half years, he can't tell you the name of any of the adults who took care of him. He didn't know any of them well enough to say.
白天，会有一组成年人来喂养和清理丹尼尔、尼库以及住在同一房间里的其他大约100名孤儿。到了晚上，则是夜班人员负责。但尽管丹尼尔在那里待了七年半，他却说不出任何照顾他的成年人的名字。因为他不认识他们中任何一个人。
He also can't tell you much about how he passed his time, what he thought about. He didn't go to school. He didn't go outside. He only left his crib to eat and go to the bathroom, so there wasn't a lot of material to draw from.
他也说不出自己是怎么打发时间的，或者自己在想些什么。他没上过学。他没出过门。他只有在吃饭和上厕所时才会离开婴儿床，所以没什么素材可供回顾。
There was one window where you could see the city. And I don't remember exactly when I started thinking about it, but you kind of started to think about, like, what is that? I know you'd see all these car lights and all the lights in the city. And I think I started thinking about, like, what is that and why am I here, not there?
有一扇窗户可以看到城市。我不记得我是从什么时候开始想这件事的，但你开始会去想，那是什么？我知道你会看到所有的车灯和城市里的灯火。我想我开始想，那是什么？为什么我在这里，而不是在那里？
One thing Daniel does remember is that he didn't spend a lot of his time yearning for a family, imagining some mother and father would drop from the sky to rescue him.
丹尼尔记得的一点是，他并没有花太多时间去渴望有一个家庭，去想象某个父亲和母亲会从天而降来拯救他。
No. I've seen several kids who had left and I'd wondered where they were going. But if I knew about it, I would have wondered, obviously, but you didn't know anything about it. It's like, a kid who never eats chocolate doesn't know what chocolate tastes like. I didn't know what a family was, and I didn't think I really thought about it at all.
没有。我见过几个离开的孩子，我会好奇他们要去哪儿。但如果我当时知道那意味着什么，我当然会好奇，可我当时什么都不知道。就像一个从没吃过巧克力的人不知道巧克力的味道一样。我不知道什么是家庭，我觉得我根本没想过这个问题。
In fact, the story of how Daniel came to have a family, whether or not he actually wanted one, begins with a kind of accident. His mother-- or anyway, the woman who would become his mother, Heidi Solomon-- got a magazine in the mail from the adoption agency that was in the process of evaluating whether she and her husband were fit to have children.
事实上，丹尼尔是如何拥有一个家庭的，无论他是否真的想要，故事的开头都源于一个偶然。他的母亲——或者说，即将成为他母亲的女人，海蒂·所罗门（Heidi Solomon）——在邮件里收到了一本杂志，来自那家评估她和丈夫是否有资格领养孩子的机构。
We were just in the beginning of our home study when we got a magazine, and it had his picture in it. And I don't really know how, because there was hundreds of pictures of kids. And I just remember telling my husband, I'm like, I think this is our son. So it was just kind of weird. Like, for some reason, his picture just, like, radiated to me.
我们当时刚开始家庭调查，就收到了一本杂志，里面有他的照片。我真的不知道为什么，因为里面有成百上千个孩子的照片。我只记得告诉我丈夫，我说，我觉得这是我们的儿子。这真的很奇妙。不知为何，他的照片仿佛在向我发出信号。
Five months later, Heidi and her husband, Rick, drove from their home in South Euclid, Ohio, to the Cleveland Airport, and took an eight hour flight to Romania to pick up their new son. Heidi is a special education teacher by profession. And she says that she felt certain ever since she was a kid herself that she wanted to adopt children-- wanted to even though she knew that adoption could be difficult, that the kid might have developmental problems or emotional problems or physical problems, or all three.
五个月后，海蒂和丈夫里克从俄亥俄州南尤克利德的家中驱车前往克利夫兰机场，乘坐了八小时的飞机飞往罗马尼亚，去接他们的新儿子。海蒂是一位职业特殊教育老师。她说，她从小就确信自己想要领养孩子——即使她知道领养可能会很困难，孩子可能会有发育问题、情绪问题或身体问题，或者三者兼有。
Heidi believes strongly that people should do what they're capable of, and she says she felt capable of adopting a child. Rick, on the other hand, had started with a more conventional fantasy, that he would have biological children. But Rick loved his wife. And so even though it hadn't been part of his original plan, he agreed. And he says that when he and Heidi finally walked off the plane in Romania and saw the dark haired child dancing on the airport ramp, he felt certain that he and his wife had made the right choice.
海蒂坚信人们应该量力而行，她说她觉得自己有能力领养一个孩子。而里克，一开始有着更传统的幻想，他想拥有自己的亲生孩子。但里克爱他的妻子。所以尽管这不在他原本的计划中，他还是同意了。他说，当他和海蒂最终走下罗马尼亚的飞机，看到那个在机场跳动的深色头发男孩时，他确信他和妻子做出了正确的选择。
You know, he was just this bouncy, smiling child who was so excited, appeared to be bright eyed and happy and happy to see us. And I think my biggest fear going in was, like, he's just going to turn his back on us and we're going to really have to fight to get his love and attention. And he was not like that at all, at least initially.
你知道，他就是一个蹦蹦跳跳、微笑着的孩子，看起来非常兴奋，眼睛明亮，看起来很开心见到我们。我想我当时最大的担心是，他会背对着我们，我们不得不费尽心思去争取他的爱和关注。但他完全不是那样，至少最初不是。
The family's early weeks back in Ohio were full of firsts-- the first time Daniel wore shoes, the first time Daniel slept alone in a bed. They played, and danced, and worked on English. And even though Daniel had some difficult moments, tantrums and fits of crying, both Heidi and Rick will tell you that, on the whole, the family had a good time.
这个家庭回到俄亥俄州后的最初几周充满了“第一次”——丹尼尔第一次穿上鞋子，第一次独自在床上睡觉。他们一起玩耍、跳舞、学习英语。尽管丹尼尔有一些困难时刻——发脾气和哭闹——但海蒂和里克都会告诉你，总的来说，这个家庭过得很开心。
This honeymoon, however, only lasted about six months. And then, Heidi says, came March.
然而，这段蜜月期只持续了大约六个月。接着，海蒂说，三月到了。
Until March, I think it was moving in a manageable direction. Like, there were tantrums, but there was progress, and there was tantrums and progress. And then his birthday is in March. And I remember at the beginning of March he said, they don't have March in Romania because I never had a birthday before. So this whole idea of a birthday was really overwhelming to him.
在三月之前，我觉得一切都在朝着可控的方向发展。虽然有发脾气，但也有进步。然后他的生日是在三月。我记得在三月初，他说，他们在罗马尼亚不过三月，因为他以前从未过过生日。所以整个“生日”的概念对他来说真的太震撼了。
And March came around-- like, that's when I started thinking, like, about the biological thing.
三月到了——那时候我开始去想，关于亲生父母的那件事。
You see, until his eighth birthday, Daniel had never confronted the idea that he had been born, and therefore that he had actual parents, people who could have, had they elected to, provided a birthday party at some point before his eighth year of life.
你们看，在八岁生日之前，丹尼尔从未面对过“自己是被生下来的”这个概念，因此也就没想过他有亲生父母，那些本来可以——如果他们选择的话——在他八岁之前提供生日派对的人。
This whole concept deeply disturbed him. And even though Heidi did her best to explain the difference between biological and adoptive families, it seems that Daniel didn't get it because he walked away from that conversation fundamentally confused about his relationship to Heidi and Rick.
整个概念深深地困扰着他。即使海蒂尽力解释了亲生家庭和领养家庭的区别，丹尼尔似乎还是没明白，因为他离开那次谈话后，对与海蒂和里克的亲子关系产生了根本性的困惑。
I started thinking that they were my biological parents, and how-- I was really mad at them that they put me there for seven and a half years, and then came and got me, like what happened. Like, why was I there for that long, and what was going on? And that's kind of, I guess, when all hell broke loose.
我开始觉得他们就是我的亲生父母，我真的很生气，为什么他们把我放在那里待了七年半，然后又来接我，到底发生了什么。为什么我在那里待了那么久，到底是怎么回事？我想，大概就是从那时候开始，一切都乱套了。
During this period, Daniel conceived a powerful hatred of his parents-- a deep anger that he couldn't shake, even after the difference between biological and adoptive parents had been explained again and again, and his actual relationship to Heidi and Rick became clear. At that point, it just didn't matter. His anger had taken on a logic of its own.
在这期间，丹尼尔对父母产生了强烈的恨意——一种深层的愤怒，即使在解释了亲生父母和养父母的区别之后也挥之不去。在那一刻，这些解释已经不重要了。他的愤怒已经有了一套自己的逻辑。
Once he learned about the idea of parents and what his had done to him, he needed to hate someone and Heidi and Rick were the people closest at hand. And so his tantrums became tornadoes of rage-- seven, eight hour marathons where he would throw literally anything he could get his hands on. Rick and Heidi say that he put more than 1,000 holes in the walls of his room until, finally, they had to move everything out of his bedroom except a mattress.
一旦他理解了父母的概念以及他们对他做了什么，他就需要恨某个人，而海蒂和里克就成了身边的人。于是他的脾气变成了愤怒的龙卷风——持续七八个小时的马拉松，他会扔掉任何他能拿到手的东西。里克和海蒂说，他在墙上砸出了1000多个洞，直到最后，他们不得不把卧室里除了床垫以外的所有东西都搬走。
They called in professional social workers and specialists, several of whom left bleeding, needing medical attention. Remember, Daniel was eight. But, really, Daniel saved the worst of it for Heidi, the person who most wanted to help him. He hated her, appeared to take actual pleasure in her pain.
他们叫来了专业的社会工作者和专家，其中好几个人是被抬着流血离开的，需要医疗救助。记住，丹尼尔才八岁。但实际上，丹尼尔把最糟糕的一面留给了海蒂，那个最想帮助他的人。他恨她，似乎从她的痛苦中获得了真正的快感。
Like, one time, he gave me a black eye when I was trying to help him. And he smiled like he was so happy that he gave me a black eye.
比如，有一次，我试图帮助他时，他给了我一个黑眼圈。而且他笑了，笑得好像给我一个黑眼圈让他特别开心一样。
And what did you think when you saw your son smiling after you--
当你看到儿子在你被打后微笑时，你在想什么？
I thought he really needs serious help, and he's very disturbing.
我觉得他真的需要严重的帮助，而且他非常让人不安。
There was a time where I remember my dad had hired this person to come to our house because my mom didn't feel safe with me in the house.
我还记得有一次我爸爸雇了人来家里，因为我妈妈觉得和我在一起不安全。
Did you get that? They essentially had to hire a bodyguard. And even so, Heidi found herself calling the police several times a month, until Heidi and Rick turned to the mental health profession. They ferried Daniel from one psychiatrist to another, and religiously followed their advice.
听到了吗？他们实际上不得不雇了一个保镖。即便如此，海蒂还是发现自己一个月要打好几次报警电话，直到海蒂和里克转向心理健康行业。他们带着丹尼尔看了不同的心理医生，并虔诚地遵循他们的建议。
One man told them to put Daniel on medication, pills for ADHD, which greatly improved Daniel's handwriting, but otherwise didn't do much to help. Another woman counseled them to buy Daniel a puppy. This also didn't work out so well.
有人告诉他们让丹尼尔服用药物，治疗多动症的药，这极大地改善了丹尼尔的笔迹，但除此之外并没有太多帮助。另一位女士建议他们给丹尼尔买只小狗。这结果也不太好。
Like, in three days, he was strangling the puppy.
三天之内，他就差点把小狗掐死。
Heidi was told by at least two psychiatrists that her son would never love her, that she should give him up to foster care. Worse, the situation with Daniel began to affect Heidi's marriage to Rick.
海蒂至少从两位心理医生那里得到建议，说她的儿子永远不会爱她，她应该把他送到寄养机构。更糟糕的是，丹尼尔的情况开始影响海蒂和里克的婚姻。
It was just so hard on him emotionally, dealing with this kid who made no sense at all. I mean, and I will tell you it put our marriage on the line. I mean, there were times when he said, I'm leaving.
对他来说，和一个根本无法理解的孩子打交道在情感上太难了。我的意思是，我告诉你，这把我们的婚姻推向了悬崖。有几次他说，我要走了。
Looking back now, I just-- I didn't want to take that step, but I certainly thought about it, just because I was so unhappy with the whole situation. Yeah. I thought about leaving.
现在回想起来，我只是——我不想迈出那一步，但我确实想过，因为我对整个局面感到太痛苦了。是的。我想过离开。
But Heidi wouldn't give up on Daniel. Changing her son became a kind of singular focus, an idea that obscured all other considerations.
但海蒂没有放弃丹尼尔。改变她的儿子成了一种单一的目标，一个掩盖了所有其他考虑的想法。
I mean, one time a case manager sat down and said, this is what I think's going to happen. Daniel's going to hurt you. You're going to be in the hospital. He'll be in juvenile detention, and your husband's going to leave you. Like, I remember that very clearly.
有一次一位个案经理坐下来说，这就是我认为会发生的情况。丹尼尔会伤害你。你会住进医院。他会被送进少管所，你丈夫会离开你。我清楚地记得这一点。
And I looked at him. I said, does this mean we hit bottom, and we can start moving up now? Like-- I mean, I'm like, that was just my response. I'm like, OK, that's your thing. Like, what do we need to do to get better? Like, I understand what the situation is.
我看着他。我说，这是否意味着我们已经触底了，现在可以开始往上走了？我当时的反应就是这样。我说，好吧，那是你的看法。我们需要做什么才能好起来？我知道情况是什么样的。
I mean, would you have sacrificed your marriage?
你是说，你会牺牲你的婚姻吗？
I didn't want to.
我不想。
The portrait that you're painting is you had to take everything out of his room. At a certain point, you kind of hired a bodyguard. It put a strain on your marriage. You called the police regularly. I mean--
你描绘的图景是：你不得不搬空他房间里的一切，雇了保镖，婚姻承压，定期报警。我的意思是——
I know, like, when you're saying it, and I said-- I mean, I feel like, OK, like, I'm crazy, when you say everything in that list. It's not like I was with the bodyguard and I'm thinking, like, wow, last week-- I wasn't, like, always putting everything together in a list like that. And just, like, this is the way our life was so I just did it. I mean, I'm, like, a really stubborn person.
我知道，当你把这一连串事情说出来的时候，我觉得，天啊，我真是疯了。我不像是在有保镖的时候还想着，噢，上周——我没有总是把这些列成一个清单。这就是我们的生活方式，所以我只是去做了。我是一个非常固执的人。
Then one day after school, when Heidi was busy making a snack for Daniel in the kitchen, he grabbed a knife from the counter and held it to Heidi's throat. No one in the family likes to talk about this episode. It clearly frightened both of them. The only thing Heidi's comfortable saying about it now is that the experience convinced her to reconsider the way she went about Daniel's education.
有一天放学后，海蒂正忙着在厨房给丹尼尔做零食，他从台面上抓起一把刀抵住海蒂的喉咙。家里没人愿意谈论这件事。这显然让他们两个都很害怕。海蒂现在唯一愿意说的是，这次经历让她重新审视了自己对丹尼尔的教育方式。
I stopped doing any kind of tutoring with him at all for a long time. Because I said, I don't want him to learn how to read. Because-- this was around the time when Columbine happened, and I was like, it's really good that he can't get any information on his own.
我有很长一段时间完全停止了对他的任何辅导。因为我说，我不想让他学会阅读。因为——那时正好是科伦拜恩校园枪击案发生的时候，我想，他无法自己获取任何信息其实是件好事。
Did you feel like Daniel was homicidal at any point?
你有没有在任何时候觉得丹尼尔有杀人倾向？
Well, I was told he was homicidal.
好吧，有人告诉我他有杀人倾向。
How do you love somebody who is homicidal?
你怎么去爱一个有杀人倾向的人？
Well, because he wasn't-- I mean, even-- because he was my son. I mean, you have to love him or else there's no way out of it. You know, it's like if you're lost, you want to keep moving forward, to get to the end place. Like, I don't think I ever question my love.
好吧，因为他不是——我的意思是，即使——因为他是我的儿子。你必须爱他，否则就没有任何出路。这就像如果你迷路了，你想要继续前进，到达终点。我不认为我曾经质疑过我的爱。
Heidi says the only time she did question whether or not she should keep Daniel was when she thought about the possibility of Daniel hurting someone else-- a fear that became more pronounced in the wake of an outside incident that happened around Daniel's 10th birthday. By that point, Daniel had been given the diagnosis attachment disorder, meaning his primary problem was that he was unable to feel connected to other people.
海蒂说，她唯一一次质疑是否应该继续收养丹尼尔是在她想到丹尼尔可能会伤害别人时——这种恐惧在丹尼尔10岁生日前后发生的一件外部事件后变得更加强烈。当时，丹尼尔被诊断出患有依恋障碍，这意味着他的主要问题是他无法感受到与他人的连接。
Heidi knew another kid who had been diagnosed with attachment disorder. She'd met him through her work, and had been so impressed with him that she actually asked the kid, who was slightly older than Daniel, to be his Big Brother.
海蒂认识另一个患有依恋障碍的孩子。她是工作中认识他的，对他印象深刻，以至于她甚至请求那个比丹尼尔稍微大一点的孩子做他的“大哥”。
I thought he was doing really well. Like, he had been featured in the newspaper. He, like, delivered Meals on Wheels. And then it was, like, President's Weekend of 2000, he committed murder. Like, I mean, he came home and just sat down on his parents' couch that night after, like, cold blooded murder, without any emotion at all. Like, and I think I had seen him the day before.
我认为他做得很好。他曾上过报纸。他负责送餐上门。然后那是2000年的总统周末，他杀人了。他那天晚上回家后，在冷血杀人之后，就像平常一样坐在父母的沙发上，没有任何情绪波动。我在案发前一天还见过他。
I mean, it was horrifying in many levels. Like, I'd worked with this kid. It was, like, and that whole professional level, but it was horrifying to me personally. Because I was like, oh, my god, here was a kid with attachment disorder that I thought was doing better, and this is how sick he really is. I was like, I will never be comfortable with Daniel.
这在多个层面上都令人恐惧。我和这个孩子一起工作过，这是那个专业层面的事，但对我个人来说是恐怖的。因为我心想，天啊，这是一个患有依恋障碍的孩子，我以为他正在好转，但实际上他病得这么重。我当时想，我永远无法对丹尼尔感到放心。
Heidi was coming to believe something that frightened her. She was coming to believe that because kids with attachment disorder couldn't connect to other people, they couldn't feel empathy. And without empathy, they didn't possess a really important human quality.
海蒂开始相信一件令她恐惧的事情。她开始相信，因为患有依恋障碍的孩子无法与他人建立联系，他们就无法产生共情。而没有共情，他们就不具备一种真正重要的人类品质。
The bottom line is these people-- like, people with attachment disorder, they don't develop a conscience, and they have the ability to hurt other people without feeling guilty. Like, that's really dangerous.
归根结底是这些人——患有依恋障碍的人，他们没有产生良心，他们有能力在不感到内疚的情况下伤害他人。这真的非常危险。
Heidi wanted her son to have a conscience. She didn't want him to be dangerous. And so she began to call around to find out more about aggressive treatments for the problem. The treatment of attachment disorder has a long and controversial history-- such a controversial history that many of the people who practice versions of the therapy decline to use its name.
海蒂希望她的儿子能有良心。她不想让他变得危险。于是她开始四处询问，以寻找更多关于针对这个问题的攻击性治疗方法。依恋障碍的治疗有着漫长且充满争议的历史——争议大到许多实践这种治疗变体的人都拒绝使用它的名字。
It was started in the mid '70s by a psychiatrist named Foster Cline, who felt that children who acted out because of an inability to connect to their parents should be forcibly regressed, made to feel helpless and hopeless so they'd return to a baby-like dependence. Early versions of the therapy involved berating children, poking them, and physically subduing them by holding them down.
它始于70年代中期，由一位名叫福斯特·克莱恩（Foster Cline）的心理医生发起，他认为那些因无法与父母建立联系而表现叛逆的孩子，应该被强制退行，让他们感到无助和绝望，从而回归到婴儿般的依赖。该疗法的早期版本包括责骂孩子、戳他们，以及通过按住他们来物理制服他们。
Therapists would sometimes direct profanity at a child, and also have the child direct profanity at them. Cline himself acknowledged that this was so harsh it was often difficult even for professionals to watch. But when outsiders criticized the treatment as sadistic, Cline responded that, quote, "These children need the kind of love that forces them to love others."
治疗师有时会直接对孩子辱骂，并让孩子也辱骂他们。克莱恩本人承认，这种方式非常严厉，甚至连专业人士都很难看下去。但当外界批评这种治疗方式是虐待时，克莱恩回应称：“这些孩子需要那种强迫他们去爱他人的爱。”
After the '70s, though, the therapy changed substantially, particularly after a couple of children died from being smothered in blankets. And by the time Heidi started hunting for something to help Daniel, most of the extreme methods of attachment therapy had been abandoned. So when Heidi heard about a doctor in Virginia who appeared to have had some success with a highly intensive program related to attachment therapy, she leaped at the opportunity.
然而，在70年代之后，治疗方式发生了实质性改变，特别是在几个孩子被毯子闷死之后。等到海蒂开始寻找帮助丹尼尔的方法时，大部分极端的依恋治疗方法已经被放弃了。所以当海蒂听说弗吉尼亚州有一位医生在依恋疗法相关的高强度项目上取得了某种成功时，她紧紧抓住了这个机会。
According to the doctor, Ronald Federici, mother and child needed to spend several months side by side, literally no farther than 3 feet apart.
根据这位医生罗纳德·费德里奇（Ronald Federici）的说法，母亲和孩子需要在一起度过几个月，字面上距离不超过3英尺（约0.9米）。
The goal of his plan is to try to recreate the bond that never occurred, because I wasn't with him when he was born. But it'd be very natural for a newborn baby to spend an extended amount of time just next to the mom, until you're trying to recreate that attachment. So Daniel and I were like three feet apart for about eight weeks.
他的计划目的是尝试重建那段从未发生的纽带，因为他出生时我不在他身边。新生儿花大量时间待在母亲身边是非常自然的，你要试着重建那种依恋感。所以丹尼尔和我保持了大约8周的3英尺距离。
I didn't go to school. She stopped her job. When she would go to the bathroom, I would be right outside the door. When I went to the bathroom, she'd be right outside the door. The only time she was not next to me was when I was sleeping. Like, literally, that was it.
我没上学。她辞了职。当她去洗手间时，我就在门外。当我上洗手间时，她就在门外。她唯一不在我身边的时候是我睡觉的时候。真的，仅此而已。
But it wasn't just being side by side. There were other elements to the program, like eye contact. Federici felt that because mothers and their babies spent a large amount of time just staring into each other's eyes, it was important for Heidi and Daniel to do the same. Daniel was required to look into Heidi's eyes during every interaction they had, and neither of them were allowed to move onto the next activity until Daniel did it correctly.
但这不仅仅是待在一起。该项目还有其他要素，比如眼神交流。费德里奇认为，因为母亲和婴儿花大量时间盯着对方的眼睛，所以海蒂和丹尼尔这样做很重要。丹尼尔在他们的每次互动中都必须直视海蒂的眼睛，在丹尼尔正确做到之前，他们谁都不能进入下一个活动。
Like, if I was talking to him, I would keep repeating what I was saying until he made correct eye contact. Like, I remember one time we spent, like, 20 minutes him handing me a notebook. Part of it, also, is he is not allowed to ask for anything. He couldn't ask-- because babies don't ask for anything.
比如，如果我在和他说话，我会一直重复我刚才说的话，直到他进行正确的眼神交流。我记得有一次，他递给我一个笔记本，我们花了20分钟。这其中一部分也是，他不允许要求任何东西。他不能开口——因为婴儿不会要求任何东西。
They learn that they're going to have their needs provided for them. So it's not that he couldn't have a treat or he couldn't have every-- he just couldn't ask. Like, we went to the store, could not ask for anything, because he had to learn that I was going to provide for him what he needed.
他们学会了他们的需求会被提供。所以不是说他不能吃点心或者不能拥有任何东西——只是他不能开口索要。我们去商店时，不能要求买任何东西，因为他必须学会我会提供他所需要的一切。
Predictably, Daniel resisted the program.
不出所料，丹尼尔抵制了这个项目。
Oh, I hated it. I totally, absolutely hated it. Yeah, I did every single thing not to do it.
哦，我讨厌它。我绝对完全讨厌它。是的，我做了每一件事来避免去做它。
Problem was every time Daniel resisted treatment, he was subjected to yet another program-dictated activity-- time-ins, the alternative universe version of time-outs. The idea is that since kids with attachment disorder prefer to be alone, every time they do something bad the response should be to make them spend even more time, even closer together.
问题是，每次丹尼尔抵制治疗，他就会受到另一个项目规定活动的惩罚——“入内时间”（time-ins），这是“暂停时间”（time-outs）的替代版本。这个概念是，因为患有依恋障碍的孩子更喜欢独处，所以每次他们做错事，反应应该是让他们花更多时间，靠得更近。
Like, we would sit on the couch and I would hug him. That was, like, his punishment.
比如，我们会坐在沙发上，然后我拥抱他。那就是他的惩罚。
Like he said, at first Daniel hated the treatment. And at least initially, his behavior actually deteriorated. But then something happened.
如他所说，起初丹尼尔讨厌这个疗法。至少在初期，他的行为实际上恶化了。但后来发生了些变化。
I think it was around the third week that I actually-- like, I was with her more. I think I realized that she's not as bad as I thought she was. I think this is kind of when it kind of changed.
我想是在第三周左右，我真的——我和她在一起待得更多。我想我意识到她并没有我想象中那么坏。我想这就是改变的开始。
Like, I didn't have as much time to hate her, I guess. And so, like, I kind of liked her a little more. Like, before, like, she would tell me not to do this. Then for, like, 45 minutes, I would hate her because she told me not to do this.
我觉得我没有那么多时间去恨她了。所以，我开始有点喜欢她了。之前，比如她告诉我不要做这个。然后有45分钟，我会因为她告诉我不要做这个而恨她。
Well, you know, there wasn't a time where I could kind of, like, go somewhere else and hate her. I was next to her. I had to live with her, whether I liked her or not. I don't know. It's just something changed.
嗯，你知道，没有我可以去别的地方恨她的时间了。我就在她身边。我必须和她住在一起，不管我喜不喜欢。我不知道。就是有什么改变了。
Daniel says he actually came to understand, maybe for the first time, that his mother loved him. The realization just dawned on him in a different way.
丹尼尔说，他其实开始理解了，也许是第一次，他的母亲是爱他的。这种认知以一种不同的方式在他心中浮现。
Both Heidi and Daniel will say that after eight weeks, Daniel was cured of his violent behavior. It was gone, done. No more tantrums, no more throwing, no more threats. But there were still problems. Instead of acting out against his parents, Daniel started stealing-- at first, just small items from the local store, but it got worse.
海蒂和丹尼尔都说，八周后，丹尼尔的暴力行为治愈了。消失了，结束了。没有发脾气，没有扔东西，没有威胁。但仍然有问题。丹尼尔没有再对父母发作，而是开始偷窃——起初是从当地商店偷些小玩意，但情况变得更糟。
After one particularly bad episode, where Daniel nearly ended up in juvie, Heidi decided it was time to go back to therapy. There was a center near their home called The Attachment and Bonding Center run by a guy named Greg Keck. Keck proposed a program that was in some ways similar to the three feet plan.
在一次特别糟糕的事件之后，丹尼尔差点进了少管所，海蒂决定是时候回到治疗中去了。他们家附近有一个叫“依恋与联结中心”（The Attachment and Bonding Center）的地方，由一个叫格雷格·凯克（Greg Keck）的人负责。凯克提出了一个在某些方面类似于“3英尺计划”的方案。
In addition to regular counseling, Daniel, who was now 13 and larger than his mother, would participate in holding therapy. That is, every night for a year, 20 minutes a night, Daniel, Heidi, and Rick were supposed to hold on to each other and talk, Rick and Heidi cradling Daniel like a newborn child, which is exactly what they did.
除了常规咨询外，已经13岁、体型比母亲还大的丹尼尔将参加“拥抱疗法”。也就是说，每天晚上进行20分钟的拥抱治疗，丹尼尔、海蒂和里克要拥抱在一起谈话，里克和海蒂像抱着刚出生的婴儿一样抱着丹尼尔，而他们正是这样做的。
I would-- even know he was really big, I would try to cradle him on my lap. Or it was really both Rick and I, because he would take up both of our laps. And I would look into his eyes the same way you would with a baby, and you make eye contact. And we would feed him with a spoon, ice cream. That's what we'd have to do to get him to-- because he liked ice cream.
我会——即使他已经很大了，我也试着把他揽在怀里。通常是里克和我一起，因为他会占据我们两个人的怀抱。我会像对待婴儿一样看着他的眼睛，进行眼神交流。我们会用勺子喂他吃冰淇淋。这是我们不得不做的——因为他喜欢冰淇淋。
It definitely feels really weird. It's like, what is this?
这感觉确实非常奇怪。就像，这是什么啊？
How did that, like, change the way you felt about them?
那这件事是如何改变你对他们的看法的呢？
Well, it's like they were feeding me ice cream. So I was like, OK, fine. But, like, it was like-- that's when I actually first started to be able to talk about what I was feeling.
嗯，他们毕竟在喂我吃冰淇淋。所以我想，好吧，没问题。但是，就像——那是我第一次真正开始谈论我的感受。
For the first time, Daniel really talked about his experience in the orphanage, opened himself up. And maybe it was the holding, and maybe it was the fact that The Attachment and Bonding Center gave Daniel a therapist he says he actually trusted, who led him through the process, but for one reason or another Daniel began to transform.
第一次，丹尼尔真正谈到了他在孤儿院的经历，敞开了心扉。也许是因为拥抱，也许是因为“依恋与联结中心”给了丹尼尔一位他真正信任的治疗师，引导他完成这个过程，总之，丹尼尔开始转变了。
There wasn't a specific moment anyone can point to. If Daniel had gone bad in one month, the going good was a lot more gradual. Without anyone quite noticing, he began to help around the house. They were able to move furniture back into his room. He started to make friends his own age.
没有人能指出具体是哪一刻。如果说丹尼尔变坏只用了一个月，那么变好则是一个更漫长的过程。在没太注意的情况下，他开始分担家务。他们能够把家具搬回他的房间。他开始结交同龄朋友。
By that point, the rabbi of their synagogue called Heidi to tell her that Daniel had won something called the Brickner Award. The Brickner is given to the valedictorian of the confirmation class, and it's a huge honor for anyone. But in the case of Daniel, it had particular weight.
到了那时，他们会堂的拉比给海蒂打电话，告诉她丹尼尔获得了所谓的“布里克纳奖”（Brickner Award）。布里克纳奖授予坚信礼班的毕业生代表，这对任何人来说都是巨大的荣誉。但对丹尼尔来说，这更有分量。
Heidi had taken Daniel to synagogue initially because she thought that it would help him to develop morals, but the training didn't take. Daniel spent several years being removed from the temple in police cars. At one point, he was actually banned from going to services. So as far as everyone, including Daniel, was concerned, the fact that he got the honor constituted a minor miracle.
海蒂起初带丹尼尔去会堂是觉得这能帮他培养道德，但训练没奏效。丹尼尔有几年是被警车从会堂带走的。有一次，他甚至被禁止参加宗教仪式。所以对所有人，包括丹尼尔自己来说，他获得这个奖项简直是一个小小的奇迹。
One element of the award is that the winner gets to make a speech in front of the entire congregation. And Daniel told Heidi and Rick that he wanted them to think of his speech as a gift. And so when Daniel took the stage, the whole family was there.
这个奖项的一个要素是获胜者要在全体会众面前发表演讲。丹尼尔告诉海蒂和里克，他希望他们把他的演讲当作一份礼物。所以当丹尼尔走上台时，全家都到了。
I spent my first half of my childhood in an orphanage in Romania. So for those years, I had no family, no love, no fun, no music, and no toys.
我童年的前半段是在罗马尼亚的一家孤儿院度过的。那些年里，我没有家庭，没有爱，没有乐趣，没有音乐，也没有玩具。
Daniel talked about his early life, and all the trouble he'd gone through since. And during most of the talk, he was smooth and composed. But then he got to the end, and even from the audience it was clear that Daniel was shaking, struggling to keep his voice under control.
丹尼尔谈到了他的早年生活以及此后经历的所有麻烦。演讲大部分时间里，他都很从容和镇定。但到了最后，即使在观众席上也能清楚地看到丹尼尔在颤抖，极力克制着不让声音失控。
Before I finish, I'd like to thank two people, my mom and dad. The reason that I'm here today and the kind of person I am today is because of you. Mom, never thank you enough for all the places you have taken me to. Even when I absolutely refused to go, I somehow had fun when I got there. Dad, you're one heck of a guy to put up with a crazy family like this. You guys are both amazing. I love you very much.
在结束之前，我想感谢两个人，我的爸爸妈妈。我今天能站在这里，以及我今天成为什么样的人，都是因为你们。妈妈，永远无法足够感谢你带我去的那些地方。即使我当时坚决拒绝去，但到了那里我总能玩得很开心。爸爸，你真是一个了不起的人，能忍受我们这样一个疯狂的家庭。你们俩都太棒了。我非常爱你们。
It was, Heidi says, without doubt the most spectacular moment of her life. The question of whether or not it's possible to teach love is not an academic one. There are plenty of people who will face this issue. Adoption these days is on the rise. Most of these children will be fine, but some of them won't.
海蒂说，这无疑是她一生中最壮观的时刻。关于是否可能“教会爱”的问题，这并不是一个学术性问题。有很多人会面临这个问题。如今，领养率在上升。大多数孩子会很好，但有些不会。
And at least on its face, the story of Heidi and Rick and Daniel seems to offer an encouraging example. Heidi and Rick were able to take a seven-year-old with no direct experience of adult affection and, with a certain amount of pain and suffering, turned him into a loving son. The only problem is that the actual participants in this story see things differently.
至少表面上看，海蒂、里克和丹尼尔的故事似乎提供了一个鼓舞人心的例子。海蒂和里克成功地接手了一个七岁、对成年人的爱毫无直接经验的孩子，并经过一番痛苦和折磨，将他培养成了一个有爱的儿子。唯一的问题是，这个故事的真实参与者们看待问题的方式却不同。
Do you feel like you can teach love?
你觉得你能教会爱吗？
No.
不能。
See, Heidi actually has a very humble view of what is and is not possible, what should and should not be expected as far as love is concerned. In fact, she tells me that, in her own mind, what she wanted from Daniel all along was very, very modest.
你们看，海蒂对什么是可能的，什么是不可可能的，以及关于爱应该期待什么，有着非常谦卑的看法。事实上，她告诉我，在她自己心里，她一直以来对丹尼尔的要求非常、非常微小。
I don't think the goal was ever love. The goal was attachment.
我认为目标从来不是“爱”。目标是“依恋”。
Do you feel like you can teach attachment?
你觉得你能教会“依恋”吗？
I mean, I think you can work really hard to create an environment where you can form attachment. You want to create these situations where it's more advantageous for them to attach than to keep doing things their own way and being in their own world, isolated.
我的意思是，我认为你可以非常努力地创造一个可以形成依恋的环境。你想要创造这些情境，让他们觉得依恋比坚持自己的方式、活在自己的世界里隔绝自己更有利。
Heidi seems utterly practical about the whole thing, even about whether or not her son now loves her.
海蒂对这一切看起来极其务实，甚至对于她的儿子现在是否爱她这件事也一样。
Do you feel loved by Daniel?
你觉得丹尼尔爱你吗？
Yeah. I feel loved by Daniel.
是的。我觉得丹尼尔爱我。
Like, in a way that you--
以一种你——
Like, I don't think he wants to hurt me. I don't, like, worry about that at all.
我觉得他不想伤害我。我根本不担心这件事。
"I don't think he wants to hurt me. I don't worry about that at all." It's a very unsentimental view of her relationship with her child, but that is probably exactly what has made Heidi so successful.
“我觉得他不想伤害我。我根本不担心这件事。”这是她对母子关系非常平淡的看法，但那可能正是海蒂如此成功的原因。
That is, Heidi is an unusually pragmatic person. She's not a flowering earth mother with a wealth of love to give. She is fundamentally realistic, tough minded, and these are precisely the characteristics that are needed in this situation.
也就是说，海蒂是一个极其务实的人。她不是一个拥有无限爱心、花朵般的“大地母亲”。她是根本上现实、头脑坚硬的人，而这正是目前这种情况下所需要的特质。
If you're the kind of person who actually needs love-- really needs love-- chances are, you're not the kind of person who's going to have the wherewithal to create it. Creating love is not for the soft and sentimental among us. Love is a tough business.
如果你是那种真正需要爱的人——真的很需要爱——那么很有可能，你不是那种拥有创造爱所需的能力的人。创造爱不属于我们当中的软弱和感性的人。爱是一门艰苦的生意。
Alix Spiegel-- she's the co-host of Invisibilia, a show on NPR about human behavior. Season 5 of Invisibilia starts this weekend. Find it wherever you get your podcasts.
阿利克斯·斯皮格尔——她是NPR关于人类行为的节目《无形》（Invisibilia）的联合主持人。《无形》第五季将于本周末开始。在你获取播客的任何地方都能找到它。
[MUSIC - "LOVELESS TOWN" BY SARAH BLUSTER]
[音乐 - 萨拉·布鲁斯特的《无爱之城》]
Coming up, another story that's going to make your job as a parent seem way easier than you felt about it at the beginning of this hour. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，另一个故事将让你的父母工作看起来比你在这一小时开头感觉到的要轻松得多。稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共电台的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- unconditional love, stories of parents and kids and how hard love can be sometimes in daily practice.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们都会选择一个主题，并带来关于这个主题的各种故事。今天的节目——无条件的爱，关于父母和孩子的故事，以及在日常实践中爱有时有多么困难。
Today show was first broadcast in 2006.
今天的节目首次播出于2006年。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. After a bunch of cases where parents of autistic children murdered their own kids, a parent named Cammie McGovern wrote an editorial in the New York Times about all the pressure that she and other parents of autistic kids feel. They hear about these amazing success stories where kids end up at Brown, at Harvard.
我们进入了节目的第二幕。在发生了一连串自闭症儿童父母谋杀自己孩子案件后，一位名叫卡米·麦戈文（Cammie McGovern）的家长在《纽约时报》发表了一篇评论，谈到了她和其他自闭症孩子家长感受到的所有压力。他们听说了那些惊人的成功故事，孩子最终去了布朗大学、哈佛大学。
But those kinds of recoveries can't happen for every kid. This is the nature of autism. "In mythologizing recovery," she wrote, "I fear we've set an impossibly high bar that's left the parents of a half million autistic children feeling like failures."
但那种恢复并不会发生在每个孩子身上。这就是自闭症的本质。“在将恢复神话化的过程中，”她写道，“我担心我们设置了一个高得不可逾越的标准，让五十万名自闭症儿童的家长感觉自己是失败者。”
For these parents, the regular parenting rulebook is out the window. There are all these different kinds of treatments. They worry about doing every possible thing. Dave Royko's son was diagnosed with autism at the age of two.
对于这些父母来说，常规的育儿手册已经没用了。这里有各种不同的治疗方案。他们担心自己是否做尽了一切可能的事。戴夫·罗伊科（Dave Royko）的儿子在两岁时被诊断出患有自闭症。
Things have gotten harder and harder over the years, and he and his wife recently had to make a decision. They had to decide whether or not to place her son in a facility for the rest of his childhood. Here he is.
多年来情况变得越来越困难，他和妻子最近不得不做出一个决定。他们必须决定是否要把儿子送到一个机构度过余下的童年。他就在这里。
People say all kinds of things to me and my wife, as parents of an autistic son. And they mean well.
作为自闭症儿的父母，人们会对我和我妻子说各种各样的话。他们是好心的。
People would sometimes say to me in public or in therapy waiting rooms-- there's a lot of interaction with parents and they would say, oh, you're a Saint. And I would just think, well, Jesus Christ, what am I supposed to? Beat the [BLEEP] out of him?
人们有时会在公共场合或治疗室的候诊室对我说——父母之间有很多互动，他们会说，噢，你真是个圣人。而我只会心想，靠，那不然我要干嘛？狠狠地揍他一顿？
Yeah.
是的。
What else would you do? Well, we have to take a lot of anti-depressants. That helps, but--
你还能做什么？好吧，我们得吃很多抗抑郁药。那有帮助，但是——
Yeah. God bless medication.
是的。上帝保佑药物。
Yeah.
是的。
People would often say, I couldn't do what you're doing. And I mean, I know some people would say that-- I mean, it's really a compliment. But sometimes they'll feel like yes, you would do--
人们经常会说，我可做不到你做的事。而且我的意思是，我知道有些人会这么说——这确实是一种恭维。但有时他们会觉得，是的，你会做的——
Right. You would rise--
对的。你会崛起的——
Unless you're really a [BLEEP] person and not cut out to be a parent, you would be doing the same thing. The only difference is we have to do it.
除非你是一个真正的人渣，不是当父母的料，否则你也会做同样的事。唯一的区别是我们不得不做。
Right.
对的。
And so don't-- and it always felt like a little whiff of this crap, like God never gives you more than you can handle.
所以不要——而且总感觉有一种这种废话的意味，就像“上帝给你的担子不会超过你能承受的”。
Right. You just want to kick those people in the teeth, don't you?
对的。你真想踢那些人的牙齿，不是吗？
That sounds harsh. Here's what it's like for us. On a typical day, our son, Ben, empties the contents of cereal boxes and egg cartons onto the floor. He opens car doors while we're driving. He walks into traffic. He throws himself up against the sliding glass door in our den. Luckily he's never smashed through, though he has put his hand through the windows in his room.
听起来很刻薄。这是我们真实的生活。在典型的一天里，我们的儿子本（Ben），会把谷物盒子和鸡蛋盒里的东西全部倒在地上。我们开车时他会打开车门。他会走进车流里。他把自己往我们书房的推拉玻璃门上撞。幸运的是，他从未撞碎过，虽然他确实把卧室的窗户打穿了手。
And by the time Ben was 12, he was nearly six feet tall and 250 pounds, a toddler in a giant's body. He dwarfed everyone in our house but me, which is why my wife, Karen's, arms are covered with bruises, scratches, and scars. I've come to call the various wounds he inflicts, "Ben-juries."
到本12岁时，他身高近6英尺（约1.8米），体重250磅（约113公斤），是一个住在巨人身体里的蹒跚学步的孩子。除了我之外，他俯视着家里所有人，这就是为什么我妻子凯伦的胳膊上布满了淤青、抓痕和伤疤。我把各种他造成的伤口称为“本伤”（Ben-juries）。
Almost daily, we experience things that other parents would recount for the rest of their lives as their biggest parenting horror story. Recently, Karen found herself in a toy store with Ben. The store owner complained about Ben's behavior. He looked her right in the eye and unloaded in his pants, which was nothing new. Crap is Ben's trump card, useful in all sorts of situations.
几乎每天，我们都会经历其他父母可能当作一生中最可怕的育儿故事来叙述的事情。最近，凯伦发现自己和本在玩具店里。店主投诉了本的行为。他直视着她的眼睛，然后在裤子里拉了一大泡屎，这并不新鲜。拉屎是本的王牌，在各种情况下都很有用。
And so she walked over, smelled it-- it smelled horrible-- and got really mad. And I said, well, can we use your bathroom? And he wouldn't let me put on his shorts, because they were wet.
所以她走过去，闻了一下——闻起来太可怕了——然后变得非常生气。我说，我们能用下你们的洗手间吗？他不让我给他穿短裤，因为短裤湿了。
And so we spent probably 20 minutes in that bathroom with me fighting him, trying to get those shorts on, and him really fighting. And I'm talking about pushing me, scratching me, and trying to get out of that bathroom. And I didn't want to let him out. He had no pants on, no underwear.
所以我们在那个洗手间里待了大概20分钟，我和他打架，试图帮他穿上那条短裤，而他真的在反抗。我说的是推我、抓我，试图从洗手间里冲出去。我不想让他出去。他没穿裤子，没穿内裤。
I'm laughing about it now, but at the time I was just beside myself. I was crying and sobbing. And finally, after a while, I looked out and that bitchy woman was there. She saw me and she said, you have to leave right now. Why did you bring him in here?
我现在笑出声来，但当时我真是快崩溃了。我哭得泣不成声。最后，过了一会儿，我往外看，那个刻薄的女人在那里。她看到我，她说，你现在必须离开。为什么你要把他带到这里来？
And so at that point, I just directed all of my anger towards her. And I said, OK, fine. We'll leave. So I just brought him out with no pants on in the store. And then, oh, my god, did she ever lose it. And so what was sort of funny was Ben really still wanted to shop. He wasn't ready to leave.
所以那一刻，我把我所有的愤怒都对准了她。我说，好吧，行。我们会离开。于是我就让他没穿裤子在店里出来了。然后，哦，天啊，她真是疯了。有趣的是，本其实还想逛街。他还没准备好离开。
Ben was only nine when we got the first serious suggestion that he needed more than we could provide at home. Two of his therapists sat us down and said that we should consider placing him in a residential program-- and the sooner, the better. As he continued to grow in size, it would only get harder to find a good program that would take him.
本才九岁时，我们就得到了第一个严肃建议，说他在家里需要比我们能提供的更多的照顾。他的两名治疗师坐下来告诉我们，应该考虑把他送到一个住宿项目中去——而且越快越好。随着他体型的持续增长，以后再想找一个能接纳他的好项目只会越来越难。
As grim as it was to imagine sending Ben away, I also found myself agreeing with them and, frankly, feeling relieved at the idea. Life had become an exhausting and sometimes frightening daily struggle to manage what was becoming unmanageable. Hearing them talk about the need for residential treatment felt like validation that, yes, things really had gotten that bad.
尽管想象把本送走很残酷，但我发现自己同意他们的看法，坦率地说，对这个主意感到释怀。生活已经变成了一种令人筋疲力尽、有时甚至令人恐惧的日常挣扎，去管理那些变得无法管理的事情。听到他们谈论需要寄宿治疗，感觉像是一种验证：是的，事情真的已经糟糕到那个地步了。
But Karen had a very different reaction.
但凯伦的反应非常不同。
I was just floored and shocked and appalled and went home and just got under my covers and cried all day. I mean, he's a baby. That's the thing that bothered me the most about the whole decision. I just always felt like I can't do it to him. It's going to be just horrible for him. And as much as this is horrible for us, I can't do that to him.
我当时彻底瘫倒，震惊且惊恐，回家后就钻进被子里哭了一整天。我的意思是，他还是个婴儿。这是关于整个决定中最让我心烦的事。我一直觉得我不能对他这样做。这对他来说太可怕了。尽管这对我们来说很可怕，但我不能对他这样做。
When I realized Karen felt this way, I found myself questioning my own values as a parent-- hell, as a person. What kind of person wants to ship his kid off to an institution? And how would Karen view me for the rest of our lives together if she ever felt like I pushed her into it?
当我意识到凯伦有这种感觉时，我发现自己开始质疑作为一个父亲的价值观——去他的，作为一个人的价值观。什么样的人会想把自己的孩子送到机构里去？如果她觉得是我逼她的，将来我们在一起的日子里，她会怎么看待我？
So I resigned myself. I decided that if we had to get through another decade with autism before Ben reached adulthood, so be it. And to avoid dropping dead from exhaustion and stress, I better get in shape. I lost 90 pounds. I exercised. I was determined to get through this and come out on the other side alive and able to enjoy life again.
所以我妥协了。我决定，如果在本成年之前，我们必须再熬过十年的自闭症生活，那就这样吧。为了避免因疲惫和压力而猝死，我最好还是锻炼身体。我减掉了90磅。我锻炼。我决心熬过这一关，在另一边活下来，并能再次享受生活。
As a parent, you want to believe that there is a cure for everything with your child. In the world of autism, there is no shortage of treatments, only a shortage of results. We were providing Ben with as much one-on-one stimulation as humanly possible, and it wasn't working.
作为父母，你想要相信你的孩子什么病都能治好。在自闭症的世界里，治疗手段并不缺，缺的是结果。我们为本提供了人力范围内尽可能多的一对一刺激，但这没起作用。
The summer before sixth grade was the toughest yet. Ben's toileting had regressed badly. He'd become increasingly aggressive. You could be sitting comfortably with Ben, looking at a book, or a TV show, and before you had time to react, his hand would dart out and put a deep scratch into your arm, or his elbow would land a hard blow to your chest, or smash your nose and send your glasses flying.
六年级前的那个夏天是最艰难的一年。本的如厕能力严重退化。他变得越来越好斗。你可能正和本舒适地坐在一起，看着一本书或电视节目，还没等你反应过来，他的手就会突然伸出，在你的手臂上留下一道深深的抓痕，或者他的肘部会猛击你的胸口，或者打烂你的鼻子，让你的眼镜飞出去。
It wasn't clear where these violent outbursts came from. Was he mad, just trying to get a reaction, playing, trying to connect? Worst of all, he would often refuse to go to sleep. Or he'd sleep, and then be up for the day at 3:00 AM. The only time Ben doesn't require direct supervision is when he is asleep, which means if he's up, one of us is up, usually Karen.
不清楚这些暴力爆发来自哪里。他是生气了，还是只是想得到反应，还是在玩耍，还是试图建立联系？最糟糕的是，他经常拒绝睡觉。或者他睡了，凌晨3点就起床开始新的一天。本唯一不需要直接监督的时候是他睡觉的时候，这意味着如果他醒着，我们其中一个就醒着，通常是凯伦。
In 13 years, Karen hadn't had one night of unbroken sleep. Summers were the worst. With no school, Ben was bored, which led to more tantrums and destructive behavior. It also meant no chance for Karen to grab an hour or two of sleep in the afternoon to make up for the night. It was this crushing exhaustion that finally did it.
13年来，凯伦没睡过一个安稳觉。夏天是最糟糕的。没有学校，本很无聊，这导致了更多的发脾气和破坏行为。这也意味着凯伦下午也没机会补睡一两个小时来弥补晚上的损失。正是这种压倒性的疲惫最终导致了这一切。
This was starting to feel like it was, like, a fatal-- Ben's autism was becoming a fatal condition for me personally. I was exhausted and can't function. And so I just couldn't do it, just I was done. I couldn't do it.
这开始让我觉得，对个人而言，本的自闭症正在成为一种致命的情况。我筋疲力尽，无法正常工作。所以我就做不到了，我受够了。我做不到。
It was just such agony over the years, taking care of Ben. And there really was no one that could sort of save us or save me or save him from this horrible situation. There just wasn't sort of enough help or enough money or anything in the world to really make this tolerable year after year after year.
这些年来照顾本真是一种煎熬。真的没有人能救我们，或者救我，或者救他脱离这种可怕的处境。世界上根本没有足够的帮助、足够的金钱，或任何东西能让这一切年复一年地变得可以忍受。
Then Ben started doing worse in school. He was regressing. His behavior and toileting were worse than the year before.
然后本在学校的表现变差了。他在退步。他的行为和如厕能力比去年更糟糕。
It really became clear that this is really bad for Ben. The best thing now isn't for him to have the nurturing of his mother 24/7. And I know you were ready for that to happen sooner.
真的很清楚，这对本来说真的太糟糕了。现在对他最好的事不再是得到母亲7×24小时的呵护。我知道你之前就准备好这一天了。
Yeah. Well, it felt nice being-- honestly, it felt nice really for us to be on the same page about this for the first time. It just felt nice being-- and part of it was it felt nice not having to feel like the parent who wasn't as good a parent. Because, in a way, it just felt like, well, am I really not as good a person, like, because I want to send our kid away? And so--
是的。好吧，老实说，对于我们第一次在这一点上达成共识，感觉真好。感觉不错——而且部分原因是不用再感觉自己是一个没那么称职的父母了。因为某种程度上，这感觉就像是：好吧，我是不是真的不是个好人，因为我想把孩子送走？所以——
I never thought you weren't a good parent.
我从未觉得你不是一个好父母。
Even more extreme--
更极端的是——
You never tried to talk me into it or convince me.
你从未试过说服我或让我相信。
Well, I think part of it is I never really felt it was really open for discussion. I mean, I felt it was just such a basic thing. How could I argue that Ben shouldn't be with mom and dad?
好吧，我想部分原因是，我从没觉得这真的可以拿来讨论。我的意思是，我感觉这是一个基本的事情。我怎么能辩解本不应该和爸爸妈妈在一起呢？
At last, we were together on this-- the single biggest decision ever in the life of our family. But there was one more person in the house whose opinion mattered, and that was Ben's twin brother, Jake. And we still had some convincing to do.
终于，我们在这一点上达成了一致——我们家庭生活中最重大的决定。但家里还有一个人，他的意见也很重要，那就是本的双胞胎兄弟，杰克。我们还需要说服他。
Jake explained to my producer--
杰克向我的制片人解释了——
Well, the first time I heard them mention it, I was-- I thought it was just so they could have more time on their hands, and I was pretty angry about that. And I told them, like, stop trying to convince yourself that this is for Ben.
嗯，第一次听到他们提这个时，我——我以为这只是为了让他们自己有更多时间，我对那感到非常愤怒。我告诉他们，别再试图说服自己这是为了本了。
It was a good point. Were we doing this for Ben or for ourselves? Karen and I had asked ourselves this question too. And if sending Ben away had only been for the benefit of the three of us, we wouldn't have done it.
这是一个很好的观点。我们这样做是为了本，还是为了我们自己？凯伦和我也问过自己这个问题。如果我们送走本只是为了我们三个人的利益，我们是不会这么做的。
Instead of being bothered by what Jake said, I was actually touched. Because after all he'd been through, all the plans canceled and events ruined, you'd still empathize with Ben, who could be so hard to empathize with. But even Jake's empathy had to take a back seat to the reality-- that it was time for Ben to go.
我没有因为杰克说的话而感到困扰，实际上我很感动。因为在经历了这一切，所有被取消的计划和被毁掉的活动之后，他仍然能与本共情，尽管本有时候很难让人共情。但即使是杰克的共情也不得不屈服于现实——是时候让本离开了。
Do you remember what it was-- where the turning point was for you? When it went from feeling like we were sending him away just for our own sake, versus the turning point where you really felt like it was a thing that was necessary?
你还记得是什么——转折点对你来说在哪里吗？当感觉从为了我们自己送走他，转变为你真正觉得那是必要的事情时？
That one night with the banging and the hitting and the screaming and the sobbing and the more sobbing and the scratching and the banging and the pounding through doors. You remember it.
那个晚上，那些撞击、击打、尖叫、啜泣、更多的啜泣、抓挠、撞击，以及砰砰撞门的声音。你还记得的。
I remembered it. It was a long, nasty tantrum late one night, where Ben lunged at me over and over with all his weight, and I ended up bloody and bruised, holding his bedroom door closed while he smashed himself against it for hours, trying to get out.
我记得。那是一个漫长且令人不快的夜晚，本一次又一次用他全部的体重猛撞我，我最终浑身是血，伤痕累累，抵住他的卧室门，而他还在里面撞了几个小时，试图冲出来。
This was extreme. I mean, there was, like, pounding and it sounded like there was punching going on. I'm not sure if there was.
这太极端了。我的意思是，有那种砰砰声，听起来就像在打拳。我不确定是不是。
Yeah. What went through your mind?
是的。你脑子里在想什么？
Well, he's certainly not happy. If he's throwing tantrums like that, he's not happy here-- not happy enough.
嗯，他肯定不开心。如果他发那种脾气，他在这里是不开心的——不够开心。
The one thing that likely never will be resolved in all of this, the thought that wakes me up in the middle of the night, is what is Ben thinking right now? Does he know he will see us again, that we still love him?
这一切中可能永远无法解决的一件事，那个会在深夜惊醒我的念头是：本现在在想什么？他知道他会再见到我们吗？他知道我们依然爱他吗？
An autistic child can't conceive of other people's subjective inner life, and that means he probably can't really wonder if we still love him, because the idea that we feel anything at all is inconceivable to him. But he certainly can wonder why the people he loves most in the world, that he has always known and relied upon and trusted, have abandoned him.
自闭症儿童无法想象他人的主观内心世界，这意味着他可能无法真正思考“我们是否还爱他”，因为他甚至无法想象“我们是有感觉的”。但他肯定会思考，为什么他生命中最爱、最依赖、最信任的人抛弃了他。
In June, we drove Ben to his new life. We were extremely lucky to live near a facility that was perfect for him-- an hour and a half drive from us in Wisconsin. After our meeting with staff and unloading Ben's stuff, it was time for us to go. It was quick. A long goodbye would only make things harder.
六月，我们开车送本去迎接他的新生活。我们非常幸运，住在一个对他来说完美的设施附近——距离我们在威斯康星州的家一小时半车程。在和工作人员会面并卸下本的东西后，我们该走了。过程很快。长时间的告别只会让事情变得更糟。
I gave Ben a big bear hug, said I'll see you soon, and headed out the door, as Karen said her farewell, which I couldn't watch. Very briskly, we walked down the hall and out of the door, accompanied by the sound of Ben's wailing. It was a strange feeling to leave an unhappy Ben with strangers.
我给了本一个大大的熊抱，说“我很快会再来看你”，然后朝着门口走去，这时凯伦也做了道别，我不敢看。我们非常迅速地沿着大厅走出门口，伴随着本嚎啕大哭的声音。留下一个不开心的本和陌生人在一起，这种感觉很奇怪。
The familiar urge to swoop in and try to calm Ben down, and protect others from any potential behavioral shrapnel, was hard to resist. We felt terrible. But at the same time, we felt liberated.
那种想要冲回去安抚本、保护其他人免受任何潜在行为碎片的冲动很难抗拒。我们感觉糟糕透了。但同时，我们也感到了一种解脱。
When we got home that evening, we were so calm that it felt foreign. It felt like we were on muscle relaxants. We hadn't realized just how tense and jangled our nerves had been for 13 years. We sank into the couch and looked at each other. Karen said, this must be what it's like to be let out of prison.
那天晚上我们回家时，我们如此平静，以至于感觉陌生。感觉就像我们吃了肌肉松弛剂。我们之前没意识到13年来我们的神经竟然如此紧张和焦虑。我们陷在沙发里看着彼此。凯伦说，被释放出狱大概就是这种感觉。
Jake and his friends were upstairs, and Karen got the idea to take them for ice cream. My immediate reflex was we can't do that. And then incredibly, three minutes later, we were in the car getting ice cream, like we'd gone through a tunnel and came out in another universe. It was even stranger for Jake. He had never known life without autism.
杰克和他的朋友们在楼上，凯伦想到了带他们去吃冰淇淋。我的第一反应是：我们不能那样做。然后不可思议的是，三分钟后，我们在车里去吃冰淇淋了，就像我们穿过了一条隧道进入了另一个宇宙。这对杰克来说更奇怪。他从未经历过没有自闭症的生活。
The first couple days, when he was gone, I was so relaxed that I was nauseous. I was, like, sick to my stomach. I felt, like, butterflies in my stomach. Like, what now?
他离开后的头几天，我放松到恶心。就像，我的胃很不舒服。我觉得，肚子里有蝴蝶。就像，接下来怎么办？
It's like I was pulled out from my life and put into another with a couple of people who I still know there, and they're with me. But it didn't feel like home anymore. For me, like, home meant stress, and it meant a 5,000 pound brother who could be dangerous at times and hogged the couch.
就像我从我的生活中被抽离出来，放进了另一个生活里，身边带着几个我还认识的人。但这不再像家了。对我来说，家意味着压力，意味着一个偶尔会有危险、占着沙发的5000磅重的兄弟。
When weekly visits with Ben began after his first month, we immediately knew we had done the right thing. Ben was happy. In fact, it is very possible that Ben is happier than he's ever been. His days are jammed with activities and tasks from morning until night.
第一个月后，当我们开始和本进行每周探访时，我们立刻知道我们做了正确的决定。本很开心。事实上，本很可能比他有生以来任何时候都更快乐。他的日子从早到晚塞满了活动和任务。
Every minute is scheduled. Even the downtime is structured, with rules and responsibilities. That's what Ben needs, and we could never have given it to him. And for us, that's what the choice boils down to.
每一分钟都是安排好的。即使是停工时间也是结构化的，有规则和责任。这就是本所需要的，而我们永远无法给予他。对于我们来说，这就是这个选择的归结。
I don't have any second thoughts. I don't feel guilty at all. I know some people, trying to be nice after he went were like, oh, you must feel so guilty or, oh, how are you and you must be doing-- just assuming that I was really doing terribly.
我没有第二次想法。我一点也不觉得内疚。我知道有些人，在他走后想表现得友善，说“噢，你一定很内疚”或“噢，你还好吗，你一定——”只是假设我真的过得非常糟糕。
And I was like, you know what? I really feel pretty good. I mean, I didn't even have to go to my shrink or anything after. I thought for sure I would be scheduling some appointments with my therapist, but I just feel it was right.
我说，你知道吗？我感觉真的很好。我的意思是，之后我甚至不需要去看心理医生之类的。我原以为我肯定会预约心理医生，但我只觉得这是对的。
Last weekend, we had our first home visit with Ben, and it was a joy. Ben walked into the house and stared momentarily at things that had changed, like the new couch in the living room. Soon we were in the backyard, and he swung on the bench swing for two hours, as happy and relaxed as I have ever seen him.
上周末，我们和本进行了第一次家庭探访，这是一种快乐。本走进屋子，盯着发生了变化的东西，比如客厅里的新沙发。很快我们就在后院，他在长椅秋千上荡了两个小时，这是我见过他最开心、最放松的样子。
He spent the rest of the day with us. And when it was time to go, Ben and I got in the car and headed back to his new home. A half hour into our drive, Ben said, "The letter D." That was my cue to say, "And D is for?" Ben countered with, "D for a dump truck." And then he said, "D is for daddy."
他剩下的时间都和我们在一起。时间到了该走的时候，我和本上了车，开车回他的新家。在车开出半小时后，本说：“字母D。”这是我提示的线索，我说：“那D代表？”本回应说：“D代表自卸车（Dump truck）。”然后他说：“D代表爸爸（Daddy）。”
I glanced in the rear view mirror and Ben was looking right at me, a rarity, and smiling. I reached back and, patting his legs, said, "That's right, Ben. D is for daddy, and daddy loves you so much." He beamed and, choking back tears, I said, "You'll always have daddy."
我看了看后视镜，本正直视着我，这很难得，并且在微笑。我向后伸手拍了拍他的腿，说：“没错，本。D代表爸爸，爸爸非常爱你。”他笑得灿烂，我强忍着泪水说：“你永远都会有爸爸。”
It's very possible Ben was oblivious to the meanings I was laying on our conversation. But I swear, it felt to me like we were on exactly the same page.
很有可能本并不清楚我在我们对话中赋予的含义。但我发誓，对我来说，感觉就像我们完全达成了共识。
That's Dave Royko. He's a psychologist in Chicago. His sons, Ben and Jake, are now both 25. Jake is a therapist at a mental health center. Ben is living in a facility in Cleveland. David and his wife, Karen, are still living in Chicago, but plan to move full time to Cleveland to be with Ben.
那是戴夫·罗伊科。他是芝加哥的一名心理学家。他的儿子本和杰克现在都25岁了。杰克是精神健康中心的治疗师。本住在克利夫兰的一家机构里。大卫和妻子凯伦仍然住在芝加哥，但计划全职搬到克利夫兰陪伴本。
[MUSIC - "I WANNA BE LOVED" BY BUJU BANTON"]
[音乐 - 布朱·班顿的《我想被爱》]
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Marie, Lisa Pollak, and Nancy Updike. Senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Music help today from Mr. Terry Miller. Additional production help from Aviva DeKornfeld, Jarrett Floyd, Kathy Hong, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney.
好吧，我们今天的节目由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人制作，参与人员还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、简·玛丽、丽莎·波拉克和南希·厄普代克。今天节目的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。音乐支持来自特里·米勒先生。额外的制作帮助来自阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、贾勒特·弗洛伊德、凯西·洪、赛斯·林德、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. Or you can download as many shows as you want, watch our videos, and do other stuff using This American Life app. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站是ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体收听我们超过600集的存档。或者你可以下载尽可能多的节目，观看我们的视频，并使用“美国生活”应用程序做其他事情。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX负责送达公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our programs co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who I tried-- I tried talking him into starting this radio show for years, until that one night--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，我试着——我试着说服他创办这个广播节目很多年，直到那个晚上——
That one night with the banging, and the hitting, and the screaming, and the sobbing, and the more sobbing, and the scratching, and the banging, and the pounding through doors that-- you remember it.
那个晚上，那些撞击、击打、尖叫、啜泣、更多的啜泣、抓挠、撞击，以及砰砰撞门的声音——你还记得的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。